aside II I know it's our song
now but it is one of the best songs to
be angry in your car alone with oh yeah
it's a really after work steering wheel
punch here yeah you Jenson I'm not
coming early in what you what my
reports gonna blow yeah no I did fill up
the coffee Janus I did I know you didn't
I also know that you cheated on
your husband at the Christmas party
come on rage I see you taking
home coffee Phil Cuzzi you see
you sit on coffee filter and I
buy dumb out of your kids catalogue
every time you bring it I don't
need corncob holders kid get a
basketball uniform the only thing worth
of that's those green fudge
frogs SiriusXM 95 hmm we're live on a
Wednesday here in a freezing cold New
York what you love what you love most
out of that by the way if we had a call
screen I would say great call or topic
call in and tell us what you've ordered
out of that kids thing me and Christine
got magazine subscriptions that we never
received magazine subscription
you gotta go chocolates I'm like when
else am I gonna be in a position impulse
buy them it's off-brand
delicious chocolates it's the
curveball very off-brand because you get
those fudge frogs I'm telling you right
now store-brand I mean you're getting
ready for the bonfire if your kid has a
catalog I promise
depending on how I'm confident not that
many people write in but if your kid has
on those catalogs are those frogs frogs
in it but a shitload of catalogues right
now do it every person the first five
people I will buy fudge frogs off your
kid yeah love them you love them I love
them the green ones you don't go peanut
butter cups right yeah I do but fudge
frogs are your frog I'm leading
with fudge frogs in the cap no the fudge
frogs are what are they there's a little
green when we get the screens out Doreen
yeah they're like Green fudge one of the
waitresses from the cellar always oh she
used to bring this analysts when Melissa
would bring the catalog I'd always get
those well I wouldn't
I'll get a magazine subscription that
would never show up in my house more
cool you're an idiot I had delicious
fudge frogs I was getting ripped taking
entrees I scratch her face off Lassie
where's my Rolling Stone oh man yeah oh
here we go you know it was I tell you
what it was actually they give you like
a voucher that we just never even so you
have to do you still have to do the work
let's do some work now that yes you
have a voucher these they're green fudge
frogs Woods find the name of them
because I am high enough that I might
order so yeah yeah yes yeah Mitch fudge
filled frogs they're by the way - dude
those are Andes candies just for the
rear and Andy candy
I'll buy you Andes candies you'll think
I'm treating it too good yeah you will
yeah oh man that's how I keep a bitch in
line how are you gonna be beyond rating
me they'll see you from the lost out
you'll see you DeAndre okay it's so hard
when we do a Lost Tapes that's so fun to
not bring it up on the live show on
Wednesday Terminator time on yeah it's
total Terminator time line we finished
the episode yeah man if you've got a kid
that's got catalogs and they got some
mint fudge FRA mint fudge filled frog
frog huh I don't know why I don't know
why they're my favorite the animal ones
all the animal fudge ones
whoever's laughing I'll fight you I'll
fight everyone in this goddamn room it's
Becky it was a ridiculous thing he just
said well you know what that's not her
fault at all it is her fault there's one
review Christine we see the one review
of this I don't know about these little
chocolate frogs amazing you're goddamn
right it was amazing
yes I would recommend to a friend of
course you would I would recommend to a
friend the Holiday Collection James I
don't want to take money out of do dog
eat chocolate-covered pretzels I go nuts
on these catalogs Chuck club pretzels
now if you get an artisan Chuck that's
what I'm talking about I mean next level
and they put like sea salt oh well
you're just an caramel and chocolate
stuff on it and that's not a hipster
that's a good childhood covered pretzel
we're also just go get flips in the
store yeah flips is the mainstream why
don't we have people why don't mean you
and I go through a couple people's
catalogs and just order candy for us and
the crew out of listeners kids to check
our sexually harassing Jacob to work
right now
but okay I put my finger in his butt
crack I definitely have my fingers but
crack this kid this can definitely get
us kicked off of air because we are in
dangerous territory right now Jacob look
at me touching his butthole
Jacob do you feel uncomfortable then J I
will have your head Jake about your job
you want to keep working here serious
dude I just give back rubs get in the
action hey Jacob if I told you I liked
it when J touches you loo this stuff I
can't do when you go into your inclusion
class next week well let me show you a
couple of don'ts now radio yeah you're
full haunch as a business I'm wearing
sweat pants too it's touching that's all
right Jacob I got these slate jeans on
that fit that's right but they're so oh
so fun man he's made these mugs fudge
filled frogs like burglary making if I'm
making your mouth water
yeah they are generic candy
you look at the ratio of mint to
chocolate I know it's so broad men's I
when I bite into it I feel like I'm
losing helps whenever I bite into a mint
fudge frog frog filled twelve
dollars I bet you get ten of its leg at
24 by the way you get charged you know
the number not only you get charged
minibar prices and those things who will
bring it you think you're getting a deal
what are the odds get what are the kids
get I'm doing this for the kids
nothing all I learned the low percentage
all profits you get to keep for any sort
of fund raising actually bring all I
learned is that I think
chocolate-covered cherries are
gross yeah they are gross that's before
somebody ate it
did you ever when you were really little
at your elementary school well I don't
know if yours did this but mine around
Christmas they like this a lot Jacob
wants me to I don't know just me to hear
you guys are just buddies Palin around
is this me - yes
that was nice I guess yeah how about
here Jake trust me Jacob trust me you
think I was coming out of this like a
scarred Abercrombie and Fitch model yes
he told me he'd put me on the bag if I
put his bag you can't break Jacob stride
today we're all coming oh dude he's all
jacked or all coming the NASCAR Sunday
we're coming over to Jacobs I mean
Witzke me is black Luke um Buckelew sick
today so he's out not coming he's not
coming on Sunday God always got a
friendsgiving yeah friendsgiving but
well I'll be there Jacob that coffee
cake is about to get the eight out
of it
yeah I'm bringing better Wawa stuff uh
you got Walla you better hope to god in
an order I don't Rock a mint fudge
filled frog order in Winnipeg Oh guys
I'm too full on guys I think I got sick
from the green dye and the turns out the
outsides chalk its job I was eating
stuff that you could write with that's a
low quality candy Dan okay chocolate at
all I would think those are delicious
and really exciting but you don't like
mint chocolate cheese Parliament just
let her talk nothing she says makes any
sense she said mint chocolate chips
literally one of my favorite ice cream
god I knew I loved you
you ever had Mediterranean mint and I'm
gonna throw hot chocolate on her is that
is that bad yeah lewd you go you're
training yet is this bad yet I didn't go
so go ahead because all bets are off
you're back in the game Lou and you
haven't gone to sensitivity training yet
no it's a mom
oh that's when they put you in
the kid lay back we're gonna plug you
into the matrix the woke matrix you're
gonna be so woke Lou wake him up I can't
Jacob you won already right I teach you
already went this because I ran it what
CJ set you straight
I think I dropped my papers again go
take-up stop it can you stop it jack I'm
the only guy who could this girl
everyone's a I mean
Christina to pepper spray him six times
in the first year
[Music]
he does learn he was a lot he does learn
though and that's what's good Lou I'm
gonna miss you I'm gonna miss an old
Mets hat getting half-cocked on a show
Witzke yeah they don't like test you to
find out if you can't possibly abide by
these rules and fire you right no
everybody has to go through it you can
go fake it enough and then get through
it oh yeah but you have to answer
questions that get a score right you
don't to find out that you're like a see
at a sexual harassing yeah you're a D at
racism errs he goes but B plus at
sharing workspaces yeah because I'm very
good at sharing works his exercises and
stuff yeah I think you guys scored can
exercise you know this hold hands with a
black person for five minutes okay like
the Coast Guard training we have to
tread water can you take notes of the
things they make you do totally yes and
then we can do them nose Jakub taking
bets right now Jacob come okay how you
doing Fred Fox plus three and a half you
want to parlay it alright so Steelers
are you gonna go moneyline a fantastic
chicken swimming a bookie gig
out of our want holes bet all right
you've reached bet tot combat time all
right giving you the best prices on the
Internet
you want the Timberwolves to cover oh
yeah Batman please all right so it's a
hundred and fifty to win a hundred there
is no Vig I'm not gonna cut you in on it
three team parlay someone stepping up
with some knots any any calls about uh
me buying fudge filled frogs out of
catalogs he's holding an email you the
catalog and fairness Vincent email me as
I said reach out no and I think you said
email said right I said right now you
want a handwritten note and send me the
catalog with a self-addressed a
self-addressed stamped envelope and we
will mail or that thing and coming back
you'll be filled out you want to live
here
my money and you'll keep your stupid
mint and I'll poop looking at your
catalog for the next three months you're
meant for I think the bullying you just
wants to like eat little frogs I do
goddamn right I think I like the shape I
think you thinking
these candies is an old-timey like own a
Buick or something love you
you know why I could never we I was
never allowed to buy the candies when I
was a kid ever ever
so do you hate do you hate old candy
like old people candy like yeah one of
my least favorite I like Werther's
Originals how about about the caramel
that had like a bar of cream in the
middle of oh that was gross
what is that cream did your dentist used
to hang out my dentist would hand out
candy which just seems I mean it feeds
itself it's smart that's how it starts
yeah but the strawberries you know that
are in the strawberry thing you take it
out it's like a lozenge but then it's
chewy
yeah the best turn like little pieces of
glass in your mouth though glass shards
the candy is wrapped in a picture of
what the candies in there it's a
strawberry oh I like those those are
real waiting for your grandmother
finished visiting with your aunt yeah
candy yeah it's dead it's office I
like it yeah I like Andy's candy all
those are gross what are those called
there's strawberry candies strawberry
candies I mean what else could you
possibly call that and you could
probably buy $40,000 with the best $4
per pound soulless candies stop saying
solos because they're not solos because
that first does follow the pound there's
gonna be so you don't have three on the
inside yet to kick out Becky owned by
Mike berry can draw berry for my great
hobby
hard Bobby chewy it's bye bitch bye
bitch yet it off by the shell they look
so appetizing man you're like gross
looking hey man yeah I'm not lying
you look like a macaroon what are you
how was your favorite thing like a
macaroon or some juice like saying
macaroons great word
you know you love macaroons I don't like
macaroons come on why you're not like
coconut anymore if that's if you are you
still a child do you think all lips are
gross and olives are gross but I love
mounds no all of you like I don't like
any hugs would you try some olives for
me to prove you're an adult because I
also I never liked olives okay but
there's some olives dude you can do like
a blackout it's a straight black with
these on pizza Hey kalamata olives
kalamata really you can eat a
jar how about this Jay oakerson this
Sunday that Jacob a tots why don't you
bring over some olives and I'll try you
get a good you get a good fetish stuffed
green under put a will under go
I'm talking about e na love see ya here
for Dana my beanie dude right now this
is me too now you don't like it because
you can't harass Jacob this is what
happens when towers taken away this what
happens in the patriarchy crumbles I
feel defenseless good and I feel good
no one's riding in no one's writing you
really want these things I'm sure you
can get there's a line we could order
online about dollars I know but I want
to help some when T for time bite-size
candies oh you're over spending money on
that maybe I'll be out on the range in
Red Dead Redemption eating some fridge
fog I wish that game hit me in any level
that it's hit you on I know it's just I
can't you gotta get into it I did I got
I'm so busy so are you how do you also
live a full Cowboys life
I don't sleep dude I sleep on the range
I'll sleep when I'm dead asleep thank
you so much man
yeah I appreciate it you're supporting
that me - we just had now dude that
molesting moment you just said to me I'm
gonna let that go because you fixed
everything fine well in his defense we
have it on camera so
countersue buddy you next time work both
nips you gotta even out man get the
tapes get the tapes right now we got the
tapes erase everything you saw we're
gonna take this case all the way to the
top for statement do a rape kit on me do
it now
we'll take him down in all his
engineering buddies will rock the
splices rape kit me what's I'm trying
another candy that I thought was just
heinous I bet you like I do like my
grandfather used to have Mary James but
I mean I couldn't think of any other
reason to eat deliver those we're I take
your teeth out what about those root
beer barrels those hard candy was a root
beer barrel didn't hate it but I didn't
love it but I'm telling you remember
Mary Jane's no no no yeah I mean they
are the heart it's supposed to be like
taffy consistency but it's the hardest
did you like now laters
no it's like a now I'm late I didn't
like my letters either because yeah I
love these there's no way you're not
gonna lose it too you get a crown dude
it's coming out oh love Mary Janes
yeah if you have any judge sugar baby
coming out did you like sugar babies
love sugar babies milk I'll tell you
what I like sugar babies sugar daddy I
like a sugar daddy don't live it on the
stick and all yeah I'll put it on
the side of my mouth
like I'll tell you what different times
of the year is it's overrated
on Halloween but the rest of the year I
think a little underrated is it tootsie
roll oh yeah but when they give it out
to Halloween and you're over it
Oh Girl Scout Samoas Garth or something
tweeting at it yeah dude mint fudge
filled frogs nose Garth you're right
those mint filled fudge frog it's
they are insanely it's their shape I'm
not shitty listen why can't we can live
in a world with Samoas he loves la ville
do you love him love then you love
macaroons I don't know if I can keep
doing the show of the guys gonna look me
right in the face and tell me lies I
don't I think honestly I don't know what
macaroons are you know what there's two
kinds of macaroons
there was this all the Slayer on law and
fairness baby baby you know no no dr.
Phil I'm gonna change my Tagalongs and
Samoas are the two best but there's two
Hana macaroons so what I'm talking about
yeah those are also custom and then
those will crow test to me
know what that is that's what I thought
a macaroon was that's why were you're
yelling at me but look look at what I
mean a macaroon is man you're a macaroon
Christine might masturbate to this
picture I've made her really grow to
love Matt would you always lie back
arune's no I used to hate coconut
oh the I've had chocolate-covered
macaroons yes great those are what's up
does I didn't know those were macaroons
I'm dumb yeah are there show them the
picture of the chocolate face all the
way on the left oh yeah that's yeah just
the best yeah but that's a taste also
when I don't have the circular small
sandwich well no I only note that is but
I've seen him I just don't know what
they even taste like or anything but uh
I think that's a flavor though what -
when I was young hated coconut yeah the
idea of coconut the only one that hasn't
changed for me the two flavors haven't
changed it I just can't stomach at all
it's coffee
black licorice you don't like coffee
coffee no the flavor alone I've come you
could do an impression of what I do when
I get a little coffee in my mouth by
accident watching you eat mushrooms at
Bonnaroo is funny because you were like
the same thing I hate it I hate it
here's another tear up but it's so funny
cuz I'm the opposite remark need some
like they're good yeah I'm like it's
like we're eating like stuff we found in
tire treads when I started doing
mushrooms in high school and I went to
college people are like oh my god take a
bagel and put peanut butter then I put
some mushrooms on it and like just
eat the mushrooms yeah don't be
a child
just chew them up have a soda
knock them back go shake hands with God
g-man in Virginia says ribbon candy was
like old people's ribbon candy by the
foot right yeah basically yeah yeah I
mean you fruit by the foot is this
gee man is that what you mean like fruit
by the foot that's gone it's a hard
candy Oh a hard candy called ribbon
candy
hard candy called disgusting my
dream I used to keep you around in a
coffee table oh man
I mean I think we're all in agreement
the best gram on candy is where there's
originals those butterscotch a lot of
butter than anything butterscotch butter
Scott for his fan cut job
butterscotch good job good job tasty
cake for recognizing making their
flagship cake the butterscotch krimpet I
know Entenmann's I from the school of
Entenmann's you know when what cinnamons
flagship thing we all know yeah come on
what is it say with me Nona from
powdered donut is the quintessential
Entenmann's it's the chocolate donut
yeah chocolate we're covered with the
yellow in the middle yeah yellow cake
chocolate donut I mean a powdered donut
guy I'm Sunita listen she I I'm not
saying that that's the butterscotch
krimpets are my favorite tasty cake even
I'm just saying that's their flagship
thing it's the most unique thing oh
their original hostess is what the
cupcakes with the swirls and the
Twinkies yeah yeah that's hostess Ho Hos
all I mean Little Debbie you got the
swiss rolls man this is i go ho ho over
a swiss roll every day the really
everybody Swiss roll I'm team Swiss roll
over here love a Swiss roll that was one
of the only that was me and my mom
loaded up on snacks we had a good snack
cabinet fruit by the foot gushers Swiss
Swiss rolls hell yeah man I could they
couldn't do that in my house I had a
problem with all those things I was like
to have it for lunch and dinner oh yeah
you were busy being athletic no I wasn't
athletic at all how's busy smoke
and butts and play with my wrestling
toys I was eating while doing voices
from my GI Joes I was outside ripping up
marble going I think I may have Papa
Shango the kid Undertaker I don't want
you look at my guys are doing right now
my guys are beat up and has a pretty
Rick wicked Royal Rumble
[Music]
you